guys this is the civil war
stable country the civil war has already
started found the best so wait is this
the civil war is it world war three
which is a civil war look at this video
let me see portland proud boys chant f
antifa pepper spraying paintball guns
using riot today in oregon the city as
clash continues oh geez
oh boy uh the entire portland police
riot squad resigned
and now in oregon city which is you know
not too far
uh
you know people are fighting with each
other this might be good news actually
because if antifa actually riots in
portland tonight which they're planning
on doing there's literally nothing
stopping them from doing anything like
this is it
deep the people in portland the auntie
for portland people just got carte
blanche the cops were like yo we out
it's all yours they won
there it is they won
you know one thing i i like about oregon
is that they have laws where if people
want to fight each other they could
fight each other without police
intervening you know i don't understand
why people can't just solve their
differences that way
and they have been yeah they have been
in some ways and uh you know i i don't
think that's a bad thing do you remember
when politicians just used to duel yeah
i mean because we don't remember but
reading about in history class like yeah
they used to just shoot at each other
and you know why i'm not necessarily
advocating for that but that's insane
and now we're like two people can't get
into it the the younger generation was
progressive
and opposed the barbaric
you know they just didn't have good aim
tim no for real that's what it was like
the younger generation
they knew they'd get
and so they wanted to eliminate uh
dueling and they did
i believe now you're not allowed to duel
yeah that's crazy man think about that
how much more is the left going to take
from us no no
what i was thinking about is like how
willy-nilly people were with their lives
like how like
yeah i'll enter mortal kombat with you
and
i wonder did they take their lives and
granted i agree that that's an insane
thing to do and people should not do
that but part of it is they just took
their principles unbelievably seriously
they were willing to die for these
things
yeah
like people died all the time back then
and just like up
guess i'll die yeah it's like up stub my
toe oh i'm dying yeah got an infection
well and we don't realize yes one of the
most common causes of death you like die
in your 30s of a toothache and so we
look at the world back then and can't
understand it but this is what's
unprecedented these videos are just so
stupid like i don't even know what's
going on at this point just let portland
eat itself why why are why are portland
proud by going and fighting with antifa
what is this like what's the point you
know what i mean like if ante wants to
go and destroy their own city okay okay
just you gotta leave man
i don't know the cops
so do you think these proud boys live
there and or they do live there yeah
okay so i guess i guess the issue uh
here is
this is exactly what we've been
predicting for some time
and uh the cops back away and say we're
not gonna do this anymore
and then locals form counter groups to
fight with and fight against antifa
because they're destroying the city and
then you end up with two factions
fighting for control or in some way
control of the streets
and there you go and it's only a matter
of time before it escalates so what is
the end result of this is actual civil
war where these individual private
factions go to war with each other is
this what it looks like because this is
like actual in the streets brawling over
i mean proud boys fighting with antifa
that sounds like yeah that's until it
gets
i think also it depends on who is the
winner or the loser i think if if antifa
gets an edge we kind of don't talk about
her as much but if the proud boys get
the edge then there's a whole
investigation and they're thrown in
federal prison and labeled terrorists
probably yeah that'll likely happen here
too
the portland with the portland right so
this is oregon city it's not portland
i want i wonder if you know how many
years it's uh it's been several years of
this ongoing escalating violence and
this is certainly the biggest of it so
maybe it just plateaus and people are
just like dude i'm so sick of watching
videos of you throwing a rock at some
guy i don't care you know what i mean
like you're not doing anything with the
cops not being in portland they might
get crazy because what if someone comes
out with a gun
yeah
or otherwise
we saw it happen last time with that one
guy who got shot and killed yeah well
we've seen police stand out many times
and not do their job especially in
berkeley just ignore riots ignore utter
violence and let things kind of play out
under the orders of uh police captains
who are like well you know we don't want
to interfere here
and many times especially during um you
know last summer there was a lot of
violence and a lot of police officers
and police chiefs that were told stand
down then they stood down so this is not
going to be something new this has
happened before
portland is one of the few places where
you actually see uh you know some of
these conflicts happen and they get
pretty crazy and even then you just see
kind of cops standing by just like that
cop in atlanta a few days ago that was
there for a drive-by shooting and just
decided to watch uh bro i'm chilling if
if it were me right now especially i'd
just be sitting there like on my phone
and people would be like oh they're
writing i'd be like oh really again
i don't yeah she got a new high score on
word crossy it's it's depressing with
the police standing down but also it's
not even something limited to riots like
we saw that happened during the parkland
shooting and the police just waited
outside yeah did he like run away yeah
he got in trouble for that didn't he
yeah
yeah they were literally
not trying to do their job as
horrible things were happening that we
can't even mention on this youtube
channel and
yeah those are the people protecting and
surfing also well then the supreme court
has said too that the police don't have
a responsibility to protect you which is
why people need to
get better defending themselves luke has
something to plug there but now it's
true no it's not even to plug there i
mean one of my friends was one of the
people that made that case very public
joe lozito interesting if you look up we
are changed joe lozito he stopped a
serial uh murderer who was on the loose
who was killing people with a butcher
knife he got stabbed in the head fought
a guy brought him down took him down as
police officers were standing by with
their guns with their batons two of them
watching the whole thing
then when they disarmed him uh then when
sorry sorry sorry when joe disarmed this
crazy serial uh killer who almost killed
him finally took him down finally threw
the knife away then the cops intervened
handcuffed uh the murderer and then
waited for backup as joe was bleeding
out almost died he woke up the next day
in the hospital and the scumbag mayor is
congratulating these police officers for
stopping a serial killer saying that joe
was a victim when joe was the one who
brought him down joe sued
and then this was brought to a very
important court case that went up the
ladder and the court ruled the nypd has
no legal duty to protect its citizens
and if they watch someone being stabbed
even though they have batons even though
they have guns they could just sit there
and watch people get stabbed uh and die
and they could legally do that uh
through the joe lizito case it's a
fascinating story the scars that joe
lozito still has on his face he got
stabbed with a butcher knife in his face
on his head all in his shoulders dude it
was this close to losing his life it's a
blessing that this man's alive he's a
hero he's a badass guy and he he
attributes
watching ufc videos to learning the
takedown of this guy with with the
butcher knife and dana white took him
out uh to a lot of the ufc shows i think
he's still on joe lozito on twitter but
if you want to see the video it's a very
powerful video and you should share it
because people need a reality wake-up
call especially the blue you know the
back to blue guys who are like hey you
gotta predict police officers uh
what are the cops go wrong uh with joel
lozito yeah where they do wrong
they took credit for something that they
never did that's fair they lied uh about
what happened and then they also waited
instead of waited for backup when they
had a wait when they had a suspect
already in handcuffs they waited for
more backup instead of calling ems and
and moving the subway cart that they
were keeping in the middle of the tracks
to to the subway tracks so so again
people need to wake up to the reality
that at the end of the day they're
responsible for themselves no one else
will and that's why being
able to defend yourself being able to
have tools to defend yourself is
something that every citizen should have
no matter what so
this is what i'm wondering like what
what could the cops have done like a
takedown on the guy like the same way
joe did you see yeah yeah take down or
baton him or or try to grab a hold of
the hand with the butcher knife i mean
there's two guys
i i and you grab the hand at least uh
you know
it's it's hard to say because a lot of
people panic and and i don't want to
make too much judgment calls especially
when it comes to uh ptsd moments where
people are in shock because people react
differently during those situations and
even when people act one way in one
particular situation that's that's high
that has high intensity they act totally
different during a different one and you
never know how someone's going to react
in those situations but at least don't
lie about it at least don't take sure
credit credit for it at least don't do
that but but if you're a police officer
you have to be trained to be ready in
those kind of situations uh i don't mean
take out a gun and shoot but if you have
less lethal munitions if you have ways
of using a baton i mean at least that
would be a lot helpful than just
watching we're we're well we're well
past the point where cops are are
obligated to do anything for anybody
again with that with that case with the
supreme court with black lives matter at
this point i wouldn't be surprised if
there's like a dude dragging a woman by
the hair she screams help and the cop
goes run and the cop runs away yeah i
literally have it on video cops running
the other way when a woman was screaming
in panic in the middle of the streets of
san francisco
uh fox news was also recording last
summer during the blm riots when people
were just going from store to store to
store police officers just standing
twiddling their thumbs watching
everything unfold not deciding to
intervene at stores and people's
livelihoods were being taken right in
front of them uh so so seeing stuff like
that should definitely make people
understand that that hey at the end of
the day you're responsible for yourself
if people are trying to disarm you like
they are in new york city where we're
seeing huge atrocious crime we saw our
82 year old punched in the face robbed
of his cane we saw a woman and child
caught in a crossfire when a madman was
trying to shoot and kill someone just
yesterday i mean the levels of violence
that are happening in new york city
where people are left
undefended where people are left
vulnerable because of these stupid
idiotic rules and laws that leave them
defenseless is just absolutely
mind-boggling
crime is going through the roof crops
are cops are under attack this is why
they're resigning and so at this point
i'm kind of just like i don't blame them
i don't i you know i i don't now we can
talk about years ago when the cops
weren't intervening but i mean even the
subway like what do they do they shoot a
guy what if they hit somebody we saw
what happened when that disgruntled
employee came out of the empire state
building and the cops shot at them and
missed and hit like seven bystanders
that's because they get really crappy
training yeah and they were literally
literally not even aiming and they and
and you know they couldn't even shoot
one guy and then i remember the story
when it first came out mass shooting
event um i think i forgot the exact
numbers but i think it was like a dozen
people shot and wounded seven i think um
i don't know the exact numbers but it
was a big number
and they couldn't even get the suspect
like what did he do yeah apparently he
didn't get shot yeah it was a bunch of
random random people got shot and i'm
like
there needs to be at least minimally an
overhaul in training i mean there's so
many police videos where they don't even
know how to how to properly take someone
down at least dude like a jiu jitsu
at least like learn how to use a firearm
at least understand the consequences and
the bullet velocity and understand how
far it will go when you shoot it through
things at least know when to use it when
not to use it and that type of training
is hard i've been doing it last summer
i'm going to be doing it again in in a
few weeks myself
it's not easy but but it's something
that if you entrust someone with that
authority when you disarm everyone else
like it's something that people should
be taking seriously i got a question
about this though like
who who's who are the people who say
back the blue like they don't live in
cities right well depends there's
there's a lot of people uh who voice
their message and also
duplicitously also fly the constitution
flag or the don't tread on me no i love
there was a meme where someone's truck
had molon labe and it also had the thin
blue line or whatever yeah you can't
have that and people were like that
you're you're defending the people who
are literally going to homes and seizing
guns from other people yeah or doing no
knock raids on red flag laws just like
they did what uh lamp these police
departments that are all screwed up are
the democrat run ones you know what i
mean like people are complaining about
rural idaho they're complaining about
new york i mean everyone has everyone
has their complaints but obviously in
bigger high density areas there's going
to be more people complaining
obviously there's going to be more
police officers obviously there's going
to be more rooms for error especially
with a larger population compared to
smaller populations where those
situations do happen asset forfeiture
does happen people do get robbed uh it
happens there's there's there's
violations of the constitution that do
happen
and and it happens far and wide
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time
you